Michael, in order to expedite these negotiations,...
...we are prepared to make you a very generous offer.
And we are prepared to reject that offer.
Michael, you haven't even heard...
Never accept their first offer.
What is your second offer?
Twelve thousand dollars.
Are you kidding me?
That is insultingly low.
I don't even wanna hear what your first offer was.
Here's the situation: your company is four weeks old.
I know this business, I know what suppliers are charging.
I know you can't be making very much money.
I don't know how your prices are so low,...
...but, I know it can't keep up that way.
I'm sure you're scared, probably in debt.
This is the best offer you're gonna get.
I'll see your situation and I'll raise you a situation.
Your company is losing clients left and right.
You have a stockholder meeting coming up and you're going to have to explain to them...
...why your most profitable branch is bleeding.
So, they may be looking for a little change in the CFO.
So, I don't think I need to wait out Dunder Mifflin.
I think I just have to wait out you.
Okay. Now, I don't know that I can get this.
I do have to go to the board for approval.
How about 60,000 dollars?
Sixty thousand.
Michael?
We're gonna have to talk about this just amongst ourselves.
Okay, done. Please, take the room.
We'll be right outside.
Take your time.
Oh my god. Oh my god.
Sixty thousand dollars?
We are so rich.